you auditioned for Twilight I did why
didn't you get that I would think you'd
be good for that I didn't really know
what it was when you audition when
you're like you know like a
run-of-the-mill act you know we're all
auditioning for all sorts of things you
just get like five pages yeah and and
then they're like act monkey when it
came out I was like hot damn right whoa
yeah were you jealous that um you
weren't in that movie just as an actress
no the only thing Emma Stone and I
actually had this conversation once
because we used to always audition for
the same thing
um which now seems silly but
um she she got one thing that I was
dying for but the one thing that really
killed me like the only time I've ever
been truly devastated by losing an
audition because most of the time you're
like ah wasn't meant to be move on what
can you do was at Tim Burton's Alice in
Wonderland uh that one devastated me did
you go see it I yeah as soon as it came
out yeah yeah and when you were like oh
and she was perfect and amazing and I
couldn't have had a British accent